his seat and he's second now he will be
called by Sir Lindsay as Lindsay's just
looking at the Clark the prime
minister's putting his red folder on the
table there so Lindsay is about to call
the Prime Minister welcome to the
statement I call on the prime minister
to move the statement
thank you Mr Speaker before I begin I
know the whole house will join me in
paying tribute to Betty boothroid who
passed away yesterday
she was a remarkable woman who commanded
huge admiration and respect as the first
female speaker of this house she was as
firm as she was fair and she presided
over many historic moments in this house
among them the debates on the Belfast
Good Friday agreement her passion with
an immeasurable contribution to our
democracy will never be forgotten and Mr
Speaker let us also send our very best
wishes to detective Chief Inspector John
Caldwell and his family he is a man of
immense courage who both on and off duty
has devoted himself to the service of
others this house stands United with the
people and leaders of all communities
across Northern Ireland in condemning
those who are trying to drag us back to
the past they will never succeed
with permission Mr Speaker I'd like to
make a statement on the Northern Ireland
protocol
of the weeks of negotiations today we
have made a decisive breakthrough The
Windsor framework delivers free-flowing
trade within the whole United Kingdom it
protects Northern Ireland's place in our
Union and its safeguards sovereignty for
the people of Northern Ireland by
achieving all this
it preserves the delicate balance
inherent in the Belfast Good Friday
agreement
and Mr Speaker
it does what many said could not be done
removing thousands of pages of EU laws
and making permanent legally binding
changes to the protocol treaty itself
that is the Breakthrough we have made
those are the changes we will deliver
and now is the time to move forward as
one United Kingdom
[Music]
[Applause]
Mr Speaker before I turn to the details
let us remind ourselves why this matters
but of the Belfast Good Friday agreement
and the reason it's endured for a
quarter of a century
it's equal respect for the aspirations
and identities of all communities and
all its three strands
but the Northern Ireland protocol has
undermined that balance how can we say
the protocol protects the Belfast Good
Friday agreement when it has caused the
institutions of that agreement to
collapse
so in line with our legal
responsibilities we are acting today to
preserve the balance of that agreement
and chart a new way forward for Northern
Ireland I pay tribute to our European
friends for recognizing the Need For
Change particularly president vondoline
my predecessors for laying the
groundwork for today's agreement and
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and my right honorable friends the
foreign and Northern Ireland secretaries
for their perseverance
in finally persuading to the EU to do
what it spent years refusing to do to
rewrite the treaty and replace it with a
radical legally binding new framework
today's agreement has three equally
important objectives
first allowing trade to throw freely
within our UK internal Market second
protecting Northern Ireland's place in
our Union and third safeguarding
sovereignty and closing the Democratic
deficit let me take each in turn
Mr Speaker call to the problems with the
protocol was that it treated Goods
moving from Great Britain to Northern
Ireland as if they were crossing an
international Customs border this
created extra costs and paperwork for
businesses who had to fill out complex
Customs declarations a limited choice
for the people of Northern Ireland and
it undermined the UK internal Market
Market a matter of identity as well as
economics
today's agreement
s any sense of a border in the IRSC and
ensures the free flow of trade within
the UK
we have secured a key negotiating
objective the introduction of a new
Green Lane for goods destined for
Northern Ireland were a separate red
lane for those going to the EU within
the Green Lane burdensome Customs
bureaucracy will be scrapped and
replaced with data sharing of ordinary
existing commercial information
routing checks and tests will also be
scrapped the only checks will be those
required to stop Smugglers and criminals
and our new Green Lane will be open to a
broad comprehensive range of businesses
across the United Kingdom I'm pleased to
say we have also permanently protected
tariff free movement of all types of
Steel into Northern Ireland
the goods going the other way from
Northern Ireland to Great Britain we
have scrapped export declarations
delivering finely completely unfettered
trade and Mr Speaker the commitment to
establish the Green Lane is achieved by
a legally binding Amendment to the text
of the treaty itself this is fundamental
far-reaching change and it permanently
removes the Border in the Irish sea
Mr Speaker perhaps the single most
important area of trade between Great
Britain and Northern Ireland is food
three quarters of the food in Northern
Ireland Supermarket comes from the rest
of the UK
yet the protocol applied the same
burdens on shipments from cairnryan to
lawn as between hollyhead and Dublin if
it was implemented in full
we would see Supermarket lorries leading
hundreds of certificates for every
individual item in every single document
checked so
less choice so today's agreement fixes
all this with a new permanent legally
abiding approach to food we will expand
the Green Lane to food retailers and not
just supermarkets but wholesalers and
Hospitality too instead of hundreds of
certificates lorries will make one
simple digital declaration to confirm
that Goods will remain in Northern
Ireland visual inspections will be cut
from 100 now to just five percent
physical checks and tests will be
scrapped unless we suspect fraud
smuggling or disease and so there will
be no need for vets in warehouses
of course to deliver this we need to
reassure the EU that food imports won't
be taken into Ireland so we will ask
retailers to Mark a small number of
particularly high-risk food products as
not for EU with a phase rollout of this
requirement to give them the time to
adjust
and more fundamentally we have delivered
a form of dual regulation for food the
single bigger sector by far for
East-West trade and one of the most
important in people's lives under the
protocol retail food products made to UK
standards could not be sold in Northern
Ireland
today's agreement completely changes
that this means the ban on British
products like sausages entering Northern
Ireland has now been scrapped
[Applause]
it's available
if it's available on Supermarket shelves
in Great Britain
in Great Britain then it will be
available in Supermarket shelves in
Northern Ireland
we will still need to make sure that
Goods moved into Northern Ireland don't
risk bringing in animal and plant
diseases but that's clearly a common
sense measure never opposed by anyone to
prevent diseases circulating within the
long-standing single epidemiological
Zone on the island of Ireland and Mr
Speaker that brings me to the treatment
of parcels if the protocol was fully
implemented every single parcel
traveling between Great Britain and
Northern Ireland will be subject to full
International customs
you'd have needed a long complex form to
send every single parcel even a birthday
present for a niece or nephew
and you could have only stopped
stopped online from retailers willing to
deal with all that bureaucracy
with some already pulling out of
Northern Ireland
today's agreement fixes all of this it
achieves something we've never achieved
before removing requirements of the EU
Customs code for people sending and
receiving Parcels families can rightly
send packages to each other without
filling in forms online retailers can
serve customers in Northern Ireland as
they did before and businesses can ship
Parcels through the Green Lane all
underpinned by data sharing by parcel
operators where they face rollout and
time for them to adjust
so Mr Speaker no burdensome Customs
bureaucracy no routine checks bans on
food products scrapped steel tariff rate
quotas fixed tariff reimbursement scheme
approved vet inspections gone export
declarations gone Parcels paperwork gone
we have delivered what the people of
Northern Ireland asked for and the
command paper promise we have removed
the Border in the eye
yeah
but Mr Speaker but Mr Speaker
to preserve the balance
of the Belfast Good Friday agreement we
also need to protect Northern Ireland's
place in our Union The Windsor framework
is about making sure that Northern
Ireland gets the full benefit of being
part of the United Kingdom in every
respect under the protocol in too many
ways that simply wasn't the case
take tax when I was Chancellor it
frustrated me that when I cut VAT on
solar panels or beer Duty in pubs those
tax cuts didn't apply in Northern
Ireland
now we've amended the legal text of the
treaty so that critical vat and excise
changes will apply to the whole of the
United king
[Applause]
Dom zero rates of that on energy saving
materials will now apply in Northern
Ireland reforms to alcohol duty to cut
the cost of a point in pubs will now
apply in Northern Ireland but because we
now have control over vat policy we can
make sure that the eu's plan to reduce
the vat threshold by ten thousand pounds
will not apply in Northern Ireland and
nor will the SME that directive that
would have brought huge amounts of EU
red tape for small businesses we're also
making subsidy control Provisions work
as intended already just two percent of
subsidy measures in Northern Ireland
fall within the scope of the EU
approvals under the protocol
nevertheless
today's agreement goes further
addressing the so-called reach back of
EU state aid law it does this by
imposing stringent new tests for the EU
to argue we're in breach of their rules
they'd now have to demonstrate that
there is a real genuine and material
impact on Northern Ireland's trade with
the EU that is a much higher threshold
than the protocol limiting disputes to
what the 2021 command paper called
subsidies on a significant scale
relating directly to Northern Ireland
we've also protected the special status
of Agriculture and fishery subsidies in
Northern Ireland which will be
completely outside the eu's common
agricultural policy all all of which
means the problem of reach back is fixed
as well as tax and spend the UK
government has a responsibility to
protect the supply of medicines to all
its citizens
our ability to do that
was constrained by the protocol
the problem is that drugs approved for
use
by the UK's medicines regulator are not
automatically available in Northern
Ireland imagine someone suffering with
cancer in Belfast seeing a potentially
life-changing new drug available
everywhere else in the UK but unable to
access it at home
and when the current grace period ends
in 2024 the situation will get worse
still expensive and burdensome checks on
all medicines companies having to
manufacture drugs with two completely
different labels and Supply chains
pharmacies needing to check every
package with complex scanners and when
eighty percent of Northern Ireland's
medicines come from Great Britain those
frictions pose a serious risk to the
supply of medicines to the people of
Northern Ireland
to fix this today's agreement achieves
something unprecedented it provides dual
regulation for medicines the UK's
regulator will approve all drugs for the
whole UK Market including Northern
Ireland with no role for the European
medicines agency
this fully protects the supply of
medicines from Great Britain into
Northern Ireland and once again asserts
the Primacy of UK regulation the same
medicines in the same packs with the
same labels will be available in every
Pharmacy and Hospital in the United
Kingdom and crucially dual regulation
means that Northern Ireland's
world-leading healthcare industry which
brings much needed jobs and investment
can still trade with both the EU and UK
markets this is a landmark deal for
patients in Northern Ireland it is a
permanent solution that brings peace of
mind
and Mr Speaker the protocol also banned
quintessentially British products going
to Northern Ireland when people wanted
to import oak trees to Mark her late
Majesty's Platinum Jubilee the protocol
stood in their way
it suspended the historic trade in seed
potatoes between Scotland and Northern
Ireland and if implemented it would
create massive costs and bureaucracies
for people traveling around the UK with
their pets disrupting family life
and our family of Nations
that's why today's agreement will lift
the ban on shrubs plants and trees going
to Northern Ireland lift the ban on the
movement of seed potatoes particularly
important for Scottish businesses and we
will deliver this by expanding the
existing UK plant passport scheme and
when it comes to pets we have made sure
that people from Northern Ireland will
have completely free access to travel to
Great Britain and if you're a pet owner
traveling from Great Britain to Northern
Ireland just make sure your pet is
microchipped and then all you'll need to
do is simply tick a box when booking
your travel
so whether it's lower VAP rates lower
bid
s and garden centers seamless travel
with pets seamless trade in seed
potatoes or the seamless supply of
cutting-edge medicines all of this now
available for everyone everywhere in the
United Kingdom
and Mr Speaker The Windsor framework
goes further still
safeguarding sovereignty for the people
of Northern Ireland and eliminating the
Democratic deficit
fundamentally the protocol meant the EU
could impose new laws on the people of
Northern Ireland without them having a
say
I know some members of this house whose
voices I deeply respect say that EU laws
should have no role whatsoever in
Northern Ireland I understand that view
I am sympathetic to it but for as long
as the people of Northern Ireland
continue to support their businesses
having privileged access to the EU
market and if we want to avoid a hard
border between Northern Ireland and
Ireland as we all do then there will be
some role for EU law so the question is
what is the absolute minimum amount
necessary to avoid a hard border
today's agreement scraps 1 700 pages of
EU law
amount of EU law that applies in
Northern Ireland is less than three
percent
and the people of Northern Ireland
retain the right to reject that three
percent through next year's consent vote
however that consent vote is about the
whole protocol so it cannot by its
nature provide oversight of individual
new laws and it does not address the
number one challenge to sovereignty made
by the protocol the ability of the EU to
impose new or amended Goods laws on
Northern Ireland without them having a
say
to address that today's agreement
introduces a new Stormont break the
storm won't break does more than just
give Northern Ireland a say over new EU
laws it means they can block them
how will this work the democratically
elected assembly can oppose new EU Goods
rules that would have significant and
lasting effects on their everyday lives
they will do so on the same basis as the
petition of concern mechanism in the
Good Friday agreement meaning the
support of 30 members from at least two
parties if that happens the UK
government will have a veto
and we will work with the Northern
Ireland assembly and all parties to
codify how their UK government will use
that veto
and let me tell the House the full
significance of this breakthrough the
storm on break gives the institutions of
the Good Friday agreement a powerful new
Safeguard it means the United Kingdom
can veto new EU laws if they are not
supported by both communities in
Northern Ireland
and yes it is true that until now the EU
had refused to consider treaty change we
were told it was impossible the EU
negotiators would never consider it but
the storm won't break has been
introduced by fundamentally rewriting
the treaty specifically the provisions
relating to Dynamic alignment that
that is a permanent change it ends the
automatic ratchet of EU law and if the
veto is used the European courts can
never overturn our decision
and the EU have also explicitly accepted
an important principle in the political
declaration it is there in black and
white that the treaty is subject to the
Vienna convention
this means that unequivocally the legal
basis for the Windsor framework is in
international law I'd like to thank my
right honorable friend the member for
stone for his support in negotiating
this point and it puts beyond all doubt
that we have now taken back control
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker from the very
start
the very start we have listened closely
and carefully to views on all sides of
this debate I'm grateful to many members
of this house the communities of
Northern Ireland and the voices of
business and Civil Society for putting
forward their suggestions I want to
particularly thank the Northern Ireland
business groups that I have spoken to
I hope in today's agreement they
recognize we have addressed their
concerns we are delivering stability
certainty Simplicity affordability and
clarity as well as strength and
representation for the businesses of
Northern Ireland
I also want to speak directly to the
unionist community
I understand and have listened to your
frustrations and concerns
and I would not be standing here today
if I did not believe today's agreement
marks a turning point for the people of
Northern Ireland
it is clearly in the interests of the
people and those of us who are
passionate about the cause of unionism
for power sharing to return of course
parties will want to consider the
agreement in detail a process that will
need time and care
and there are of course many voices and
perspectives within Northern Ireland and
it is a job of government to respect
them all
but I have kept the concerns raised by
the elected representatives of unionism
at the Forefront of my mind because it
is their concerns with the protocol that
have been so pronounced and what I can
say is this our goal
has been to ensure the economic rights
of the people of Northern Ireland under
the act of Union and Belfast Good Friday
agreement placing them on an equal
footing with the rest of the UK with
respect to tax trade and the
availability of goods
and we have worked to end the prospect
of trade diversion removed any sense of
a border for UK internal trade removed
routine Customs or checks for goods
destined for Northern Ireland removed
thousands of pages of existing EU law
and introduced a UK veto on Dynamic
alignment through the storm won't break
we have created a form of dual
regulation where it works and it is
needed most in sectors like medicines
and food retail we have delivered
unfettered access to the whole UK market
for Northern Ireland's businesses and we
will take further steps to avoid
regulatory Divergence in future we've
secured a clear EU commitment and
process to manage future changes with a
special Goods body and all of this means
Northern Ireland's businesses have
continued access to the EU Market as
they requested
it means we have protected the letter
and the spirit of Northern Ireland's
constitutional guarantee in the Belfast
agreement with this storm on break
creating an effective cross-community
Safeguard there are Mr Speaker two
distinct economies on the island of
Ireland and that will remain the case
today's agreement puts beyond all doubt
that Northern Ireland's place in the
internal market and United Kingdom is
fully restored Mr Speaker I want to
conclude by directly addressing the
question of the Northern Ireland
protocol bill as I and my predecessors
always said
the bill was only ever meant to be a
last resort meant for a world where we
could not get negotiations going
governments said at the time of
introduction
remains a negotiated solution now that
we've persuaded the EU to fundamentally
rewrite treaty text of the protocol we
have a new and better option
the framework delivers a decisively
better outcome than the bill achieving
what people said could not be done and
what the bill does not offer it
permanently removes any sense of their
Border in the Irish sea it gives us
control over Dynamic alignment through
the storm on break beyond what the bill
promised and the bill did not change a
thing in international law keeping the
jurisdiction of the ecj and leaving US
Open to months maybe years of
uncertainty disruption and legal
challenge today's agreement
makes binding legal changes to the
treaty itself and is explicitly based in
international law and unlike the bill it
is an agreement that provides certainty
stability and crucially can start
delivering benefits almost immediately
for the people and businesses of
Northern Ireland of course the house
would expect to be informed of the
government's updated legal position on
whether there is a lawful basis to
proceed with the bill so I'm publishing
it today it says that because we have
achieved a new negotiated agreement
which preserves the balance of the
Belfast Good Friday agreement the
original and sound justification legally
for the bill has now fallen away
in other words
neither do we need the bill and nor do
we have a credible basis to pursue it as
such we will no longer longer a seed
with the bill
and the European Union will no longer
proceed with their legal actions against
the UK
instead we will pursue the certainty of
a new way forward with the Windsor
framework and let me just remind The
House of the full breadth and
significance of what we have achieved
today we've achieved free-flowing trade
with a green Lane for goods no
burdensome Customs bureaucracy no
routine checks on trade no paperwork
whatsoever for Northern Irish Goods
moving into Great Britain and no border
in the Irish sea
protected Northern Ireland's place in
the union with state aid reach back
fixed the same tax rules applying
everywhere vet certificates for food
Laurie's gone the ban on British
sausages gone parcel paperwork gone pet
paperwork gone Gordon centers now
selling the same trees supermarkets
selling the same food and pharmacies
selling the same medicines and we've
safeguarded sovereignty for the people
of Northern Ireland with the Democratic
deficit closed the Vienna convention
confirmed thousands of pages of EU law
scrapped and with a storm on break we
have safeguarded democracy and
sovereignty for the people of Northern
Ireland so that is a choice before us Mr
Speaker let us seize the opportunity of
this moment the certainty of an
agreement that fixes the problems we
Face commands broad support and
consensus and offers us at last the free
them to move forward together that is
what the people of Northern Ireland
deserve that is what the Windsor
framework delivers
as a conservative a brexiteer and a
unionist I believe passionately with my
head and my heart that this is the right
way forward right for Northern Ireland
right for our United Kingdom and I
commend it to this house
thank you what I want to do is make sure
we get everybody in this is a very
important day I know called The Leader
the opposition
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you to
the Prime Minister for advanced side of
this statement and for the briefing I
was given earlier this afternoon I'd
like to start by joining the prime
minister in paying tribute to Betty
boothroid
picker of this house
she was at the 4 front of a generation
that smashed the glass ceiling for
female politicians
she wasn't inspirational woman a
dedicated and devoted public servant who
will be clearly missed by all who knew
her my thoughts the thoughts of the
whole house are with her very many
friends and family
Mr Speaker The Good Friday agreement and
the peace and prosperity it brought to
Northern Ireland are amongst the
proudest achievements of the last Labor
government
but we in labor have always recognized
this achievement does not principally
belong to us but to the people of
Northern Ireland who over a quarter of a
century have overcome differences that
once seemed insurmountable and showed
that they can work together to build a
better future for themselves and for the
generations to come
I have the privilege of working for a
number of years with the Police Service
of Northern Ireland so that it can serve
and represent both communities
but it's the police officers themselves
who carried out that change they help
make peace of the Good Friday agreement
stick
so I was deeply saddened by the shooting
of DCI John Caldwell and our thoughts
the thoughts of the whole house are with
him his family and with his colleagues
but Mr Speaker DCI Caldwell shooting is
a reminder that we must continue to
strive for peace that we in the house
would take our obligations under the
Good Friday agreement and to the people
of Northern Ireland as seriously as they
do
it is in that spirit that I have been
clear for some time
that if the Prime Minister were to get
an agreement with the EU
and if their agreement is in the
interests of this country and Northern
Ireland
then labor would support it
and we will stick to our word we will
not snipe we will not seek to play
political games and when the Prime
Minister puts this deal forward for a
vote labor will support it and vote for
it
the protocol will never be perfect it's
a compromise
but I've always been clear that if
implemented correctly it is an agreement
that can work in the spirit of the Good
Friday agreement
and now that it has been agreed we all
have an obligation to make it work
the moral core of the good fight
agreement is simple
all people of Northern Ireland have the
right to identify themselves and be
accepted
as Irish or British or both and freely
participating in the economic life of
the UK or the Republic of Ireland is an
essential part of that
that is why it is good but the deal
before us will see fewer unnecessary
checks on Goods moving between Great
Britain and Northern Ireland
the red and green Lane proposal is a
good one it will make life easier for
business it will enable the people of
Northern Ireland to participate more
freely in the economic life of the UK
it has our full support
the protocol will continue to ensure
there's no physical border on the island
of Ireland
that is essential
we all know that any physical border
will be a source of tension a physical
manifestation of new barriers between
communities in Northern Ireland and the
economic life in the Republic
this agreement will allow us to move
forward as a country
rather be locked in Endless disputes
with our allies
it will improve our diplomatic standing
which has been damaged by the
government's previous threats to break
international law
and I am encouraged that the dup has
said it will look carefully at the
measures that it contains
but we must be honest this comes with
trade-offs the right honorable member
for Uxbridge and South ruislip told the
people of Northern Ireland
that his protocol meant no forms no
checks no barriers of any kind on Goods
crossing the Irish sea after brexit that
was absolute nonsense a point-black
refusal to engage with unionists in
Northern Ireland in good faith never
mind take their concerns seriously
and it inevitably contributed to the
collapse of power sharing in Northern
Ireland and I have to say as the Prime
Minister listed all the problems with
the protocol I did rather wonder whether
he'd forgotten who negotiated it
so so
when when presenting what this agreement
means in practice and it will take time
for everybody to read it and carefully
consider it I urge the prime minister to
be utterly unlike his predecessor do not
pretend the deal is something it is not
where there are trade-offs to be made
argue the case for them treat unionists
with the respect of Frank honesty not
the contempt of Bluster
because in this 25th anniversary year of
the Good Friday agreement we must once
again Embrace compromise and put
Division behind us
this deal is not perfect
but because we recognize that the UK
agreed to the protocol and has no
obligation to make it work
because we recognize that for the
protocol to work that will inevitably be
trade-offs and because we always
recognize that peace and prosperity in
Northern Ireland is hard one labor will
support the Windsor framework
I hope that in coming days others will
come to support the agreement In The
Same Spirit and join labor in voting to
make the protocol work in voting to face
the future in voting for country before
party thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker can I Thank The
Honorable gentleman for his comments and
support uh I I agree with him on the
substance of what he has said and I
would just say to him that at this
moment in time the right thing for all
of us to do is not to Look Backwards but
to look forwards to the brighter future
that we can see for Northern Ireland
he told he talks the trade off and for
me I I would talk of balance
and the delicate balance inherent in the
Belfast Good Friday agreement
and it's important that we respect the
aspirations and identities of all
communities and that's what the protocol
had unbalanced and that's what the
Windsor framework restores and I do
believe hand on heart that the changes
we have achieved the framework that we
now have in place will enable balance to
be restored to the people of Northern
Ireland it puts them in control of their
Destiny it secures their place in the
union it safeguards their sovereignty
and on that basis
I hope we can look forward to a brighter
future for everyone in Northern Ireland
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker my first associate
myself with the remarks made both by
honorable friend and the leader of the
opposition about baroness boothroid an
outstanding speaker and DCI John
Caldwell
the Northern Ireland protocol negotiated
and signed by the government in December
adopted the European Union's preferred
proposal of a border down the Irish sea
can I congratulate my right honorable
friend and the Secretary of State for
Northern Ireland and the foreign
secretary and all their teens for all
the work they have done to achieve this
negotiated settlement which will make a
huge difference and does my right
honorable friend agree with me that the
best move now is for everybody across
this house to support this settlement
because that is what is in the best
interests of all the people of Northern
Ireland
okay uh thank my honorable friend
enjoying her and paying tribute to the
Northern Ireland foreign secretaries
they deserve enormous credit for the
framework that we have achieved today
and can I tribute to her for all her
work over the years on this topic where
she has kept safeguarding the Union at
the top of her mind throughout and I
agree with her what all of us should
have at this moment at the top of our
minds is the people of Northern Ireland
and what is in their interest and I hope
when people have the time and space to
consider the Windsor framework that they
will see that this is the best way to
move forward and build that better
future in Northern Ireland SMP
spokesperson Stephen Flint
thank you Mr Speaker I I think I'm the
Greek leader but I'll take spokesperson
as well uh the glass ceilings glass the
glass ceilings
are there to be broken
didn't just break a glass ceiling she
shattered the grass the glass ceiling in
in that regard she has my Opera of most
respect and my thoughts and condolences
are with her and all of her family
members my thoughts are also with the
police officer
in Northern Ireland who is so tragically
an appallingly shot in recent days I
sincerely hope that he is able to make a
recovery and I join with members across
the house in that regard Mr Speaker to
the
agreement today you'd be forgiven for
thinking on the basis of what the Prime
Minister has said and in the chamber and
indeed earlier today that they had
absolutely nothing to do with him that
all those problems were nothing to do
with the conservative party yeah or
indeed him as a government minister so
what what happened a couple of years ago
well they simply being opportunistic
when they put this in place well the
incompetent when they put this in place
or were they simply duped into believing
that something was already went quite
clearly it was not I have no doubt that
the public will draw their own
conclusions in that regards
but Broadway speaking Mr Speaker broadly
speaking I'm fully supportive of
fairly supportive of The Grieving for
three simple reasons
three simple and interwoven reasons it
seeks to safeguards peace in Northern
Ireland something which we all know is
incredibly important the seeks to
protect the Good Friday agreement which
is of course protect the Good Friday
agreement which I think everyone in the
chamber the degree is incredibly
important and of course because it seeks
to provide a pathway back to the
Democratic institutions in Northern
Ireland being able to sit now it's not
for me to pontificate about democracy in
Northern Ireland but I sincerely hope
that those parties involved will be able
to come to an agreeable conclusion and I
know the Prime Minister shares My Views
in that regards but Mr Speaker whilst
all of that is good we cannot and we
should not forget the damage which has
been done by leaving the European Union
brexit has been an unmitigated disaster
and they don't they don't have to
believe me
because
because what they should do is read The
obr Who outlined that there'd be a four
percent hit to GP as a result of X or
perhaps they should reflect upon the
back the fact that the trade deficit
between the UK and EU as it is highest
level on record perhaps they could
listen to private sector those
businesses who are unable to treat those
businesses who are unable to get the
workforce that they require those
businesses who are able to get the goods
that they need or perhaps they could
listen to the public sector who of
course are facing severe problems as
well many of them driven by Workforce
shortages indeed many of the problems
which Encompass and face all of our
nhs's across these Isles come from the
fact that we have significant staff
shortages in Social care each and every
one of those points Mr Speaker as a
result of the disaster that has been
leaving the European Union yeah and I
just find it astonishing Mr Speaker that
we have a situation where the leader of
the labor party and the leader of the
conservative party are hands and glove
when it comes to their position
[Applause]
but just finally just finally Mr Speaker
we heard we heard Integrity of the
United Kingdom spoken about at length by
the Prime Minister indeed I think it was
reflected upon by the leader of the
opposition as well
but whilst there may be a scintilla of
Truth within the argument what this deal
does not do is create parity for the
Nations of these Isles because what it
allows say the Northern Ireland Minister
sitting there he was very positive about
this in an interview earlier on it means
it means that businesses in Northern
Ireland have access to the single Market
whereas businesses in Scotland do not
now I do not begrudge
that to the people and businesses of
Northern Ireland but I do I do regret
that Scotland does not have those same
opportunities so on that point can the
Prime Minister just clarify why
is that a significant disadvantage in
that regard on his watch I did he does
he not agree with me that the only way
for Scotland to have access to the
single Market the only way for Scotland
to have access to the Customs Union the
only way for Scotland to rejoin the
European Union is to rid itself of
Westminster
prime minister
Mr Mr Speaker can I uh thank the
honorable Jensen for his support for the
new agreement that we struck today the
Windsor framework in particular his
acknowledgment of the sovereignty that
it provides for the people of Northern
Ireland to have a say in their own
destiny something that was asked for and
something that has been delivered uh
he's also right to say that it's not for
us any of us to opine and we will give
the parties and the communities in
Northern Ireland the space and the time
they need to consider the detail of the
winter framework uh and more broadly Mr
Speaker without engaging on the broader
debate that he raises you know I I am a
passionate unionist and I will always
believe that our Union is stronger when
we are together and Scotland will always
alongside Northern Ireland Wales be part
of what makes this country great and we
will fight we will fight day in and day
out to protect that Union
allows to Peter bottomless
Mr Speaker the deed of deposition
helpless said that people in Northern
Ireland micro guns as Irish or as
British or as British and Irish I think
a large number also regard themselves
this is Northern Irish
I think that from the beginning to the
end of this framework
the beginning which says the protocol
has been the source of acute political
economic and societal difficulties to
the last sentence which talked about the
shared desire for a positive
relationship
constituents will say this agreement
resolves some of the known problems
about the protocol and some of the ones
become obvious since then
it's over 50 years or about 50 years
since it was last a unionist MP who was
the minister of the UK government I hope
this agreement makes it possible that
can happen again
[Music]
or can I uh can I thank the father of
house for his support and his
observations uh he he's right about the
agreement that we struck it resolves the
problems that we know about but it also
puts in place structures and mechanisms
to resolve anything else that might come
down the line because it's important
that there is dialogue not just for the
European Union but close dialogue with
communities and businesses in Northern
Ireland something they have asked for
and as a result of this agreement they
will have new engagement new ways to
make their voices heard so that we can
continue to make sure that we do the
best for them and their communities in
Northern Ireland Sir Jeffrey Donaldson
thank you Mr Speaker and could I on
behalf of the democratic unionist party
add our voice in tribute to the late
Betty boothroid who was my first Speaker
a wonderful woman who brought so much to
this house and could I also add Our
concern and our sympathy to the family
of DCI Caldwell where he continues to be
in our prayers Mr Speaker and I was
pleased to stand with the other leaders
in Belfast but the chief Constable on
Friday and to be clear the people who
perpetrated this evil have no place in
the future of Northern Ireland
Mr Speaker our judgment and principal
possession in opposing the protocol in
Parliament and at Stormont I believe has
been Vindicated
undoubtedly it is now recognized that
the protocol does not work
and when others said there could be no
renegotiation and no change it was our
determination that has proven what can
be achieved and I would like to thank
the Prime Minister and his predecessors
for their work on engagement to date on
this issue
in Broad terms it is clear that
significant progress has been secured
across a number of areas whilst also
recognizing that there remain key issues
of concern
there could be no disguising the fact
for example that in some sectors of our
economy in Northern Ireland EU law
remains applicable in our part of the
United Kingdom
my party will want to study the detail
of what has been published today as well
as examining the legal tax the political
declaration and the government's command
paper
where necessary We Stand ready to engage
with the government
in order to seek further clarification
reworking or change as required
ultimately my party will now assess all
these proposed outcomes and Arrangements
against our seven tests outlined in our
2022 Assembly Election Manifesto to
determine whether what has been
published meets those tasks on whether
it respects and restores Northern
Ireland's place within the United
Kingdom Under This regard and finally Mr
Speaker
I agree with the Prime Minister that the
issue of sovereignty is crucial
article 6 of the act of Union the very
basis of the Union itself the economic
Union of the United Kingdom was
seriously undermined by the Northern
Ireland protocol and its implementation
and that needs to be resolved of the 77
billion pounds of goods manufactured in
Northern Ireland
65 billion pounds of that 77 billion are
sold within the United Kingdom the
overwhelming majority of what we produce
we sell within our own internal market
and I want an assurance from the Prime
Minister that not just now but in the
future
the government of the United Kingdom
will protect Northern Ireland's place
within that internal market and will not
allow the application of EU law to put
barriers in the way of our ability to
trade with the rest of our own country
Mr Speaker can I first of all start by
thanking the right honorable friend for
the constructive engagement that I've
had with him and members of his team
over recent time as I said earlier
I've tried very hard to listen in
particular to the concerns of the
elected representatives of the unionist
community in Northern Ireland because I
know it is them who have had the most
concerns with the protocol and at the
Forefront of my mind throughout all our
negotiations has been resolving the
issues that those communities have
raised with me and the government that
they are grappling with I believe very
strongly that the Windsor framework does
resolve those issues but I appreciate
that the right normal gentleman and his
party and other unionist communities
will want to take the time to consider
the detail and I respect that and we
will give them the time and the space to
consider that and stand ready to answer
any questions and provide any
clarifications but I also can tell him
with regard to the objectives that he
set out and others have set out that I
believe that this agreement this Windsor
framework does Ensure the free flow of
trade within our United Kingdom internal
Market including unfettered access for
Northern Ireland producers to the rest
of the United Kingdom I do believe it
secures Northern Ireland's place in the
union making sure that citizens and
businesses can benefit in the same way
everywhere across the north the United
Kingdom and lastly and as he is rightly
highlighted to me on previous occasions
it ensures and safeguards sovereignty
for the people of Northern Ireland so
that they are in control of their
Destiny I believe that what we have
achieved today does provide the basis
for parties in Northern Ireland to
consider the detail and hopefully move
forward so together we can build a
better future for Northern Ireland and I
look forward to doing that with him
during this late committee Simon Hall
thank you thank you Mr Speaker my right
under defend the Prime Minister and his
ministerial Comics have strained every
sinew these these last weeks and months
to arrive at today's position they are
to be congratulated and Mr Speaker it
demonstrates
that when committed Minds do politics
seriously serious and beneficial
outcomes can be delivered for the
benefit of all in our country
whilst respecting entirely and agreeing
with my right honorable friend that
parties particularly those in Northern
Ireland need the time and space to study
the detail and to work out all of the
implications for those in Northern
Ireland
Northern Irish business wants and the
good people of Northern Ireland most
certainly deserve quick certainty so if
there are to be votes in this place
on any element of the Windsor framework
as announced today can my right Uncle
friend commit to ensuring that those
those votes take speed that take place
speedily in order to ensure that
certainty and peace of mind for all who
either live in Northern Ireland or who
wish Northern Ireland well
prime minister can I thank my friend and
the chair of the select committee is the
subject that he knows well and is
passionate about rightly and I thank him
for all the work he and his colleagues
have done over the years which has been
valuable as we have considered and
concluded these negotiations as I said
earlier today Poland will of course have
it say and there will be a vote but we
will need to do that at the appropriate
time as we give people the time and
space to consider the detail but he
makes an important point and the benefit
of this framework this agreement is that
it can start providing that certainty
and those benefits to the people and
communities of Northern Ireland very
soon and that's why we have concluded
these negotiations and we want to start
delivering those benefits for people on
the ground as quickly as we can ED David
can I join others in paying tribute to
our late great speaker Betty boothroyd
Mr Speaker like me I'm sure you remember
with fondness when you caught speaker
boothroid's eye and when she brought you
to order uh can I also uh send our
thoughts and prayers to DCI John
caudwell and his family and thank him
for his courage and bravery yeah
Mr Speaker like others the liberal
Democrats were now closely study this
deal but can I welcome the spirit of
partnership and compromise between the
UK governments and the European Union in
the formation of the Windsor agreement
can I ask the Prime Minister what
consultation he will now undertake with
all Northern Ireland's political parties
including the alliance party on the
storm and break
can you reassure us for the operation of
the storm and break will not undermine
the economic stability and certainty or
the political stability so desperately
needed in Northern Ireland
I'm happy to give the right honorable
gentleman the assurance that we will
continue as we have done to engage with
all parties and communities in Northern
Ireland that is the right way to proceed
particularly with regard to the
operation of the break that set out in
the command paper that we look forward
to discussing that and how to codify
that with the executive the assembly and
political parties as we move forward
that's something that we're very happy
to do and just so the Ronald gentleman
is clear the the storm won't break is
based on an existing Good Friday
agreement mechanism the petition of
concern mechanism it's well established
in Northern Ireland as a cross-community
safeguard that's why we have chosen it
as the appropriate mechanism for this
particular purpose but as I said we will
continue to engage with all parties to
make sure that we get it absolutely
right and how it works Julian Smith can
I join tributes to
[Applause]
have I joined tributes Caldwell who was
who was shot whilst learning footballs
into his car having trained kids a
football match you know my last week in
front of his son
I welcome the winter agreement and
Windsor framework and I believe that
today marks a critical moment in ending
three years of instability across
Northern Ireland this has affected
communities throughout this most fragile
part of our country I pay tribute to my
right older friend and the team for all
that they have done to secure this
would you agree that we now need to give
my right honorable friend uh member for
Lagan Valley uh all the other Northern
Ireland parties time and space and
encouragement to restore power sharing
and to ensure that political decision
making in Northern Ireland can start as
soon as possible prime minister
can I pay tribute to my honorable friend
my neighbor not just for the job he did
as Northern Ireland Secretary of State
but for his continued passion and
Devotion to the people of Northern
Ireland and can I also thank him
personally for the support and advice he
has given me in helping us reach the
framework today I wholeheartedly agree
with him and I hope that we can move
forward with time and space to build a
better future for the people of Northern
Ireland I know that that's what he wants
to see I join him in wanting to see that
and we stand ready to work with everyone
to bring about that outcome
thank you very much indeed Mr Speaker
can I congratulate the negotiators on
this very significant achievement
can I also congratulate the Prime
Minister on his statement in which he
was so Frank about the Manifest failures
of the original Northern Ireland
protocol negotiated and signed by his
predecessor which made today's deal so
necessary does he agree with me that the
European Union has moved a long way in
these negotiations
and does he agree that all of this in
this house look forward as soon as
possible to the restoration of power
sharing in Northern Ireland because that
is in the best interests
of the people of that part of our United
Kingdom Minister
um well I thank the Rhino gentleman and
he's uh he's right we have had
constructive and good negotiations with
the European Union and I pay tribute to
the president Ursula Von de lime for the
leadership and vision that she has
demonstrated in trying to find a way
through to help us resolve these issues
uh she and her team deserve enormous
credit for displaying that Vision
leadership and creativity and I
wholeheartedly agree with him that the
people of Northern Ireland need and
deserve their institutions to be up and
running I think that's something all of
us in this house agree on and all of us
want to see that happen as soon as
practically possible David Davis
congratulating my right or friend on
what seems to be a spectacular
negotiations
in the winter framework the Prime
Minister has succeeded in delivering a
deal which eliminates the issues the IRC
border deals with practical issues in
Northern Ireland from food to pets to
plants to Parcels from medicine
regulation to tax rules but above all
has introduced the extraordinary
mechanism of the Stormont break I am
unaware of any mechanism in any
International agreement like the storm
upgrade it seems to me a brilliant piece
of negotiating insight and Imagination
yeah could you explain to the house
because we won't all know in detail can
you explain to the house exactly how
this mechanism will work and what its
limitations were prime minister uh well
can I can I thank my honorable friend
for his uh warm words but also tell him
it means a lot as this is something that
I know as a brexiter of long-standing
credentials and as someone who has done
the job he uh he knows how difficult
these things are and to have his support
means a lot to me and the government and
I thank him for it um the the break will
work as I said on the basis of the
petition and concern mechanism which is
a good Friday agreement institutional
framework which wise why we believe it
is the right cross community Safeguard
to use it will be applied to those good
rules in Annex II of the protocol which
was the main cause of concern uh and
it's there for those rules that cause
significant and Lasting uh damage and
change to the everyday ordinary lives of
people in Northern Ireland and once that
emergency break is pulled it will give
the UK government a veto it is a very
powerful cross-community Safeguard
mechanism that ensures sovereignty for
the people of Northern Ireland and it is
part of why this agreement is the right
one for the people of Northern Ireland
thank you Mr Speaker can I uh be
associated with the remarks about belly
Birthright can I also uh join with my
colleagues particularly my colleagues in
Northern Ireland uh sending our love and
support to the Caldwell Family and every
single psna officer in a farm today
standing up for our peace and democracy
once we have some concerns particularly
about the storm and break and we will
study the detail of this as we go we are
happy today uh that things seem to have
uh moved I would say though Mr Speaker
there's been an awful lot of talk
particularly today and over the recent
months about the concerns of the dup and
the unionist community it is important
to remember that the majority of people
in Northern Ireland oppose brexit and do
want to see the benefits of dual Market
access properly utilized will the Prime
Minister agree with me that it's
important now that his government
support that and promote that to
International investors Minister well
can I Thank The Honorable gentleman uh
for his engagement with the secretary of
state and myself over recent weeks and
he is right
there is a balance to be struck in the
Good Friday agreement is about
respecting that balance about the
aspirations and identities of all
communities and Northern Ireland and
that is what we are sought to achieve
with with the framework and as I
outlined earlier something that I and we
have heard loud and clear from
businesses in Northern Ireland is that
they do value their access to the single
Market they do value as all of us do not
having a hard border between the
Northern Ireland and the Republic and
that is something that we have had to
bear in mind as we considered these
negotiations but I believe we have
struck the right balance and the
framework means that this agreement can
command the support and consent from
communities right across the Spectrum in
Northern Ireland and I look forward to
working with him and his party to
deliver it Randall Lewis
thank you Mr Speaker and can I please
also uh give my say my best wishes and
align myself with comments from others
uh earlier today around this
particularly detective Chief Specter
John Caldwell it's a very Stark reminder
of the courageous and very special work
that all PSI officers do every single
day that they are working to keep all
people in Northern Ireland safe and we
owe them all a great debt uh for that
work Mr Speaker can I just say to my my
right honorable friend he's absolutely
right I congratulate him and my
colleagues on the front bench for the
phenomenal Focus that they are putting
into ensuring that we can secure a deal
that we all know will hope can restore
power sharing installment which is
absolutely key for people in Northern
Ireland to get back to having good
governance in Northern Ireland by
elective representatives in Northern
Ireland another key area for the
citizens of Northern Ireland is access
to Goods as he is rightly outlined can
he just confirm for the house today that
in these still we will only not only be
able to secure free flow of trade for
Northern Ireland businesses to Great
Britain but also for Great British
businesses into Northern Ireland
although regulations were preventing
some Goods it's great to know that the
Great Yarmouth Banger will be able to
get back on the supermarket shells where
required in North London but for me
businesses it was the administrative
burden of moving from Great Britain to
Northern Ireland not just regulatory
that needed to be removed to allow them
to see it as an economic benefit and
therefore protect the structure and
integrity of the UK internal Market
uh can I uh can I thank my honorable
friend but also pay tribute to him for
the work that he did on this topic uh in
his role as Secretary of State for
Northern Ireland it was invaluable in
Paving the way for me and my colleagues
to take forward that work and bring it
to a successful conclusion today and
he's right to highlight the
administrative burden of moving goods
from Great Britain to Northern Ireland
I'm confident that with the new Green
Lane based on using existing ordinary
commercial data and data sharing in
place of the bureaucratic customer
Arrangements that were there either too
it is an enormous step forward it
delivers what businesses have asked for
we work closely with the business
community in Northern Ireland to develop
it and I'm confident as they study the
detail they will see that it provides
that smooth flow of their goods around
the United Kingdom as it should be and
ensures Northern Ireland's place in our
UK internal Market the George Howard
thank you Mr Speaker could I welcome the
fact that the
document contains a number of references
to the need for cross community support
and the Prime Minister has repeated that
phrase a number of times in his
statements and in responses he will be
aware Mr Speaker that the over the last
25 years one of the significant
developments has been a number of people
who identify themselves as Northern
Irish as distinct from either British or
Irish could he give the house some
indication of how he's going to gauge
the opinion of that 20 of the population
who identify them in cells in that way
but might not necessarily be represented
by a political party
prime minister to say to The Honorable
gentleman that you know my uh my
approach to this and indeed the approach
of my honorable friend the secretary of
state is to engage with all communities
all parties or business groups in
Northern Ireland because Northern
Ireland is about balance it's about
respecting the Delica balance that
exists in Northern Ireland that was at
the heart of the Belfast Good Friday
agreement and as I think he's seen we
have gone out of our way to talk and
listen to everybody respecting of course
the particular concerns of the unionist
community that this framework this
agreement I believe gets that balance
right it respects the aspirations and
identities of all communities in
Northern Ireland and that's why I
believe it is the right way forward so
William cash
speaker my right honorable friend will
know that in the papers have been
published this afternoon the devil as
ever lies in the detail
may I seek his assurance that the
government will respond to the
democratically correct questions that
naturally arise on the substance and
procedures that are involved
and particularly on the making of EU
laws and the European Court
particularly on the joint committee and
its procedures and of course the storm
won't break not to mention that the
whole context of sovereignty in this
entire process under Section 38 of the
war withdrawal agreement act 2020 and
would he also be good enough to indicate
how long a timeline he's proposing for
the questions and answers that will be
required and how long that might take
well Mr Mr Speaker can I thank my
honorable friend for the engagement that
he's had with me in particular for the
advice that he has provided at section
38 of the withdrawal agreement was a
testament to him and it reasserts the
sovereignty of this Parliament uh and in
matters of international law and he was
right to do it I hope that we can
strengthen actually that particular
Clause as we consider how best to make
sure that we protect the active Union in
Northern Ireland place in it but I would
also say to him in terms of questions
I'm happy to move as quickly as he's
able to provide the questions for me and
look forward to engaging in that
dialogue with him
Stephen Curry thank you Mr Speaker my
party can give a broad welcome to this
agreement there are some positives in it
that address a range of challenges that
have been clear for a a some period of
time however however for us the key test
is a preservation of North Ireland's
dual Market access and in that regard my
party has massive concerns around this
potential storm and break so those are
prime minister understand that there are
real dangers that this process could add
more instability into the assembly and
kind of stress to him that the
professional concern is controversial
given its abuse in the past and also
create uncertainty for businesses
regarding ongoing Supermarket rules
particularly with a huge investment in
the Northern Ireland so when he beat
with our party discusses more detail the
clarify what's what's potentially being
proposed can I uh can I thank the
honorama gentleman for the engagement
that he and his colleagues have had with
me in the Secretary of State over the
recent weeks it's been helpful and of
course not going to show him I look
forward to talking to him again very
soon to explain the Windsor framework in
detail and he makes a good point there
are many people communities businesses
in Northern Ireland that value their
access to the European Union single
Market they value rightly not having a
hard border on the island of Ireland and
we have strived to protect that in this
agreement whilst ensuring Northern
Ireland's place in our Union and
protecting and safeguarding its
sovereignty I believe that the Windsor
framework does get that balance right
and I look forward to having that
conversation with him
Shabbat penny Mr Speaker can I say at
the outside our thoughts and prayers are
with the police officer who was attacked
by people calling themselves the new IRA
and there's nothing new about people
that are callous murderous or attempted
murderers they're still the IRA and they
always will be by the dates when I
served in the province
populate the Prime Minister on
negotiating this excellent agreement but
part of the reason that the EU has moved
perhaps was the threat of the European
Bill coming through this house they
clearly woke up and smelt the coffee as
to how bad it was going to be for them
and for the Republic of Ireland and do
you think that was part of the reason
why he got such an excellent deal with
the European Union
well Mr Speaker I'm sure that the the
bill did create the conditions for us to
have the negotiation that we did but as
the government said at the time and was
clear about that its preference was
always a negotiated outcome if one was
available and today we have achieved a
negotiated outcome that provides a
certainty and stability that we need
that resolves the issues that we set out
to resolve its safeguards Northern
Ireland sovereignty it protects its
place in the union and guarantees and
provides for the free flow of trade
around the UK internal Market is because
we now have the Windsor framework this
new agreement that we no longer need the
bill and we will no longer proceed with
it and this agreement can start bringing
benefit to the people of Northern
Ireland as quickly as possible thank you
Mr Mr Speaker as chair of the uh all
party group on Ireland and the Irish and
Britain the state of relationships
between London and Dublin in the last
few years has been of great concern to
many of us and the hundreds of people in
this place who work who are of Irish or
Irish origin so we need to look to the
future we need to learn from that
and that in mind he talks about the Good
Friday agreement in all its Dimensions
that includes strands two and three that
offer us great potential if they're
fully implemented to embed some of this
agreement and look to the future will he
now permit his party and other members
here join in making sure that the
operation of strands two and three and I
cooperated with the Irish government
goes forward in a much better sense than
it has prime minister I I tell the
honorable lady that the government has
committed to all strands of the Belfast
Good Friday agreement I talk a lot about
balance and making sure that we get that
balance right but I would pay tribute to
borrow offender Secretary of State and
indeed uh The Honorable my honorable
friend member for Wickham for the
incredible job that they have done not
just with the agreement but in
particular addressing the issue that she
raised and I'd also put on record my
thanks to the Irish government for the
role that they have played and the
support they have provided us throughout
this process we look forward to
continued positive and constructive
dialogue with them that's what my
colleagues and I will do as we make sure
that we capitalize on all strands of the
Belfast Friday agreement they're managed
thank you Mr Speaker Northern Ireland
has such a precious and integral place
in the United Kingdom and it certainly
seems to me reflecting back over the
last five years that at any point in
that time if this deal had been on the
table those of us who are brexiteers
those of us who are remainers those of
us who are unionists would have jumped
on it so I really heartily congratulate
the Prime Minister the foreign secretary
the Secretary of State and the minister
of State for their excellent work and
negotiation here but can the can my
right honorable friend assure us that in
his view this Windsor agreement now
fully restores the act of Union and the
Belfast Good Friday agreement
prime minister I um can I thank my
honorable friend uh particularly for her
support given you know her long-standing
credentials in this area and the passion
with which she believes in our Union I'm
grateful to have her support and I also
can give her that Assurance this
absolutely does meet the requirements
and consistency with the active Union in
the Belfast Good Friday agreement uh as
she rightly said we've worked very hard
to get to an outcome that does and I'm
really pleased that the Windsor
framework delivers for her and everyone
else in Northern Ireland Sammy Wilson
that's great speaker I welcome the
18-minute confession which the Prime
Minister undertook about the damage
which the protocol which his government
signed has done to Northern Ireland
but could I remain the Prime Minister
that although he talks about 1700 pages
of EU law being removed from Northern
Ireland hundreds of thousands of pages
will still remain border posts are still
being plannedly built and the Prime
Minister has admitted that future EU
laws will apply to Northern Ireland
unless under paragraph 52 his government
decides not to proceed with Law changes
in for the United Kingdom as a whole or
hey vetoes EU proposals in The Joint
Committee can I understand why we don't
have confidence in that and why we still
fear that the our position within the
United Kingdom is not going to be
restored by this agreement
uh Mr Speaker I I think as The Honorable
gentian knows well that the Border posts
are there to deal with checks in the red
lane uh and it's something that was
always envisaged it's always something
that we said we would do it's right that
for people trying to smuggle Goods into
the Republic of Ireland via Northern
Ireland that shouldn't happen and that's
why those uh posts are there those
inspection facilities and the investment
in them is to make sure that we can do
those checks properly as we assure the
European Union we would do and that's
part of having a functioning Green Lane
is having enforcement of the red lane
and to his broader point about EU law as
I said uh less than three percent of EU
law applies in Northern Ireland it
applies with the consent of the people
of Northern Ireland as he knows the
consent vote next year allows them to
remove all of these uh these laws and
have a new a new approach but it is
there because as we've heard there is a
balance to be struck and Northern
Ireland's communities businesses do
value not having a border on the island
of Ireland they do van value their
access to the single market and we're at
the position where we have the minimum
amount of law required to fulfill that
purpose but I believe sovereignty is
important I believe those laws as they
come through and new ones as you
mentioned come through should only come
through with the consent and oversight
of the people of Northern Ireland and
that's why the storm won't break is so
powerful it puts power in the hands of
the Assembly of him and his colleagues
to decide what's best for Northern
Ireland that's what sovereignty means to
me it means giving Stormont the ability
to say no and I hope that he will give
this framework the time and
consideration it deserves Mark Francois
thank you Mr Speaker
I thank the Prime Minister for his
statement
and also for publishing both the white
paper and the legal text on the same day
which will materially assist the whole
house
as a former Chancellor
he knows well that on budget day
the government put a good gloss on
whatever they're putting to the public
but then you have to read through the
red book to just check on the fine
detail
he's worked very hard on this
so can he assure me and the whole house
that when we go through the red book or
in this instance the detailed legal text
we won't find any nasty surprises which
would materially undermine the position
of Northern Ireland and the United
States prime minister can I uh can I
thank my honorable friend for his
comments and I'm pleased that we were
able to publish all the documentation I
know this was something that was
important not just to him and there are
a member for stone but other colleagues
as well it's the right thing to do and
as I said I want to give everybody the
time and the space to consider the
detail of the Windsor framework I
believe it meets the objectives that we
set out to do it provides for the free
flow of goods within the United Kingdom
it ensures Northern Ireland's place in
our Union and it's Safeguard sovereignty
for the people of Northern Ireland I
look forward to engaging with him and
his colleagues over the coming days to
answer his questions and provide any
clarifications and I'm confident that
when he goes through the detail he will
see that this is a good agreement it is
is the right agreement for Northern
Ireland for the people of Northern
Ireland and it's a way for our United
Kingdom to move forward together
thank you Mr Speaker and can I associate
myself with the comments and sentiments
for the families of Betty boothroid and
DCI Caldwell the people of Northern
Ireland have been through so much this
is a very welcome opportunity to make
progress but as the prime minister no
doubt knowns clearing up the messes that
other peoples make can be a never-ending
job
Lords is currently debating a bill that
will delete over 60 areas of Regulation
which are not covered by the protocol
a process that the EU has already said
will start a trade War if it goes
through that the Northern Ireland Human
Rights Commission says undermines the
Good Friday agreement it covers issues
like electrical safety and food
standards and farming standards
so in order to support what he's
presented to the house today will the
Prime Minister confirm that all
remaining retained EU legislation will
be retained in Northern Ireland itself
using the piles that he has that
Stormont currently can't exercise
because if he doesn't how can anybody
have confidence that we will avoid the
regulatory Divergence and that trade war
that could undermine everything he's
presented today prime minister well Mr
Speaker the the rule Bill and that
legislation is passing separately to
these uh Arrangements but what these
Arrangements do provide for is for the
appropriate sovereignty in Northern
Ireland for the um storm assembly to
have that say more than I say to be able
to block new Goods EU Goods laws as they
come down the pipe if they're not happy
with them and as you'll see in the
command paper we've committed to a range
of other things to ensure that we
protect against trade and Regulatory
Divergence including including dialogue
with businesses in Northern Ireland but
also with the European Union and as she
studies the detail hopefully she'll be
reassured that we've protected properly
against that it's Ryan Duncan Smith Mr
Speaker can I associate myself with my
right-handled friend's comments on Betty
boothroid who was my first Speaker when
I arrived here uh she'll be greatly
missed and also with the comments about
the brutal attack on Peter call them uh
can I commend my right normal friend for
his diligence hard work and that of his
team in pursuing this regardless of this
of the obstacles that line his way from
a reluctance of the EU to admit anything
about the problems that have been taking
place as a result and can he uh remind
him that for me at the end of the day
the restoration of the Good Friday
agreement as having served in Northern
Ireland myself and lost friends who
didn't come back from Northern Ireland
is the number one item that I see but on
that I noticed when I was looking
through that the storm won't break is
not quite as defined as it might be and
I just wondered if you could clear this
up I see there's a phrase there that
says it can only be used with a
significant impact specific to everyday
life and I wondered who makes that
decision as to what marks significant
and the second point is can the EU
demand countermeasures if it is deployed
by them prime minister can I thank my
honorable friend for his comments and
pay tribute to his service I know this
is a topic he rightly cares about uh and
I'm happy to clarify it is is for us to
make that determination uh whether the
threshold has been met it's right that
there is a threshold this is a serious
mechanism the ability to be able to
block new law it shouldn't be used for
trivial uh reasons it should be used for
those new laws which do have a
significant a lasting impact on the
everyday lives of people in Northern
Ireland so that is the right trigger
it's one that we are in control of
deciding and it's equally appropriate
that if we do do that that the EU will
have the right to take uh appropriate
counter measures that's there in black
and white those obviously have to be
proportionate I don't think anyone could
disagree with that but this is a very
powerful mechanism and I'm pleased that
we're able to reach resolution on it
because as I said it ensures that we
have restored sovereignty to the people
of Northern there's several Roberts
there is of course much to welcome in
today's statement but I must press the
Prime Minister on a specific in his
statement the Prime Minister casually
mentioned that the burdens on shipments
between hollyhead and Dublin he failed
to mention that pre-brexit around 30
percent of all trade through the port
that went to went on to Northern Ireland
from Dublin that trade is reorientating
as we speak in real time aggravating the
already devastating impact of brexit on
the port of holyhead
can the Prime Minister clarify whether
this new agreement will guarantee
seamless trade between Northern Ireland
and Wales via Dublin and if not will he
recognize that green Lanes will
disadvantage Welsh ports ah a minister
well Mr Speaker what this is about is
ensuring the free flow of goods within
our United Kingdom that's what the Green
Lane is there to do it is always going
to be the case after we left the
European Union that's sending things to
the European Union from the UK would be
different and what this agreement is
about is prioritizing trade within the
United Kingdom's internal market and the
Green Lane that we've delivered through
this framework does exactly that yeah so
John Redwood you will decide which EU
laws would apply in Northern Ireland and
on what basis will they make that
decision
prime minister well going forward Mr
Speaker when the executive is up and
running as I hope very much that it will
it will be for the assembly in Northern
Ireland to decide for those good rules
in Annex 2 which are the ones of most
concern the storm won't break will apply
there will be a process of scrutiny and
using the petition of concern mechanism
uh that 30 mlas from two parties can
trigger the storm won't break which then
allows the UK government to veto them uh
at that moment so that's why this is
important because now it will be the
institutions of Northern Ireland they
get to make that decision
Ian Paisley
Mr Speaker we have my sincere
uh comments to the attempted murder on
DCI call well a person who was on his
family who known personally to me and I
thank the Prime Minister for the
comments and I hope
that The Sovereign will in fact make a
statement about the attempt of murder of
a police officer in Northern Ireland I
think it would be appropriate unfitting
the prime minister is quite rightly
indicated that trade is so important to
all of our United Kingdom in paragraph
47 of the paper it indicates in
particular with regards to Veterinary
medicines for our animals our agri-food
sector is huge it feeds multiple bills
of millions of people here in GB yet it
says that half of all product lines are
at risk and as part of this agreement we
have put in place a grace period
Arrangement that will expire in less
than a year and a half
prime minister that is utterly useless
for our agricultural sector that will
actually make it more difficult for our
farm businesses our livestock too if we
move it from County Antrim to airshar we
would have to leave our livestock there
if it wasn't sold in the march in their
shower for at least six months that has
not been addressed if if the prime
minister to move cattle from Yorkshire
to Lancashire was told that we'd have to
stay in Lancashire for six months he
would be not amused by that our farmers
are not amused in Northern it is our
single large trade will these issues be
fixed or is this a field process already
yeah prime minister well I joined with
Laura gentleman in supporting our
Farmers whether in Northern Ireland or
indeed in Yorkshire and actually with
Veterinary medicines where the very
medicines the the agreement we have
reached it lasts three years till the
end of 2025 which provides us with the
time and space to agree a more permanent
solution with the European Union which
has today's framework demonstrates we
are more than capable of doing as we
have resolved all the other issues that
were in front of us and I would Point
him to the solution that we have reached
on human medicines which I think
everyone can agree are of vital
importance where we have achieved a form
of dual regulation which ensures the
full availability of medicines across
the entire United Kingdom whether the UK
regulatory authorities being the ones in
charge I think that is what he should
look to alongside all the other things
that we have sold today to have
confidence that between now and three
years in 2025 we will put a permanent
footing for vet medicines on the table
can I warmly welcomed the statement for
my right honorable friend and commend
him and his entire team and what they
have achieved he seems to have won some
jaw-dropping concessions from the EU
without giving anything in return but
can I ask him if uh he agrees with me
that alongside the benefits this
agreement will bring for the people of
Northern Ireland that it can form the
basis of further cooperation with our EU
friends on issues that will matter to
the entire United Kingdom so including
for example trading Investments science
cooperation and illegal migration
can I thank my Ronald friend for his
support but also his advice over the
past few weeks as well which has been
invaluable and I do agree with him and
he's right to highlight in particular
illegal migration as well as economic
economic cooperation this is a priority
for this government and as we have
demonstrated the home secretary's work
working with the French that cooperation
is yielding benefits and we can continue
to want to do more of that and I know
that he will support those efforts okay
Hannah thank you very much Madam Deputy
speaker I Echo the words of solidarity
for many across the house for the
Caldwell family and for the psni and the
rejection of extremist Throwbacks who
the people of our region are sick and
tired of we all want to see simpler
post-brexit trading arrangements so we
sincerely welcome this progress and
command the Prime Minister on taking a
much more constructive approach than his
predecessors I will reiterate that there
are many political outlooks in Northern
Ireland and it is a fact that most
people most parties and most business
Representatives value our single Market
access our high food standards and our
1998 agreement so that we maintain the
huge opportunity of the protocol will he
commit his government well debate
continuing in the House of Commons over
the Windsor framework the replacement
Reese soon access for the Northern
Ireland protocol more coverage at the
top of the year
[Music]
thank you